Good morning, Hank, it's Tuesday.
I want to talk about Ukraine today, but this
is extremely complicated and I just want to
apologize in advance for anything that I get
wrong / leave out / over-simplify.
Okay?
Okay!
So this is Ukraine, the second largest country
in Europe by area.
And this is the Crimean Peninsula, which saw
much of the fighting in the Crimean War that
lasted from 1853 to 1856.
It was sort of a 'Catholic versus Orthodox'
thing, but the larger cause was Europe fearing
that Russia's power would expand as the Ottoman
empire declined.
So Britain, France, and the kinda-still-a-thing
Ottoman Empire teamed up to eventually defeat
Russia and five hundred thousand people died,
and it was generally pretty awful, and obviously
resolved very little since Europe - just sixty
years later - would go ahead and have World
War I. Then towards the end of World War I,
Russia had its famous communist revolution
and Ukraine enjoyed a brief period of independence.
Although 'enjoyed' may not be quite the right
verb.
In fact from 1917 to 1921 Ukraine was mired
in endless wars among competing factions including
Poland and the USSR and Ukrainian Nationalists,
even some real live anarchists.
It was all very complicated.
It was also extremely violent.
More than 1.5 million people died.
And then finally Ukraine became part of the
USSR, and things became more stable for a
while, but then...
Stalin.
As many as 10 million Ukrainians starved to
death in 1932 and 1933 thanks to Stalin's
agricultural policies, which were not just
stupid but also actively evil.
I mean, there was widespread starvation in
a country that is now the world's third largest
exporter of grain.
Then following World War II, Stalin forcibly
deported the Crimean peninsula's entire indigenous
population of ethnic Tatars to central Asia.
So if you wanna point to one individual who's
responsible for a lot of this, I don't wanna,
you know, call anyone out, but STALIN.
Stalin also moved many ethnic Russians into
Ukraine, especially into the Crimean peninsula
in the western part of the country, which
is the industrial center.
And then Stalin's successor, Khrushchev, decided
to transfer the Crimean peninsula from Russia
to Ukraine in 1954.
Why?
Well, Khrushchev had lots of ties to Ukraine,
but also the Crimean peninsula is not actually
physically attached to Russia.
As you can see here, it is physically attached
to Ukraine and it gets all of its electricity
and water from Ukraine, and it's easier to
administer places you are physically connected
to.
Which is why Alaska should be part of Canada,
but that is a different story.
Okay, so quick contemporary demographic snapshot:
today, about 67% of people living in Ukraine
speak Ukrainian as their first language.
About 30% speak Russian, although only about
17% of the population identify as ethnically
Russian.
And as you can see here Russian is mostly
spoken in the West (he meant East) and in
the Crimean peninsula.
Many Tatars have returned to Crimea since
the breakup of the Soviet Union, but today
they only make up about 12% of the population.
Okay, so flash forward to December of 1991
after the Soviet Union has broken up: Ukraine
has had a nationwide referendum and 90% of
people, including a majority of those living
in the Crimean peninsula, voted for independence
from Russia.
But Ukraine remained much more closely aligned
with Russia than many other former Soviet
Republics did like, for instance, Estonia,
which is now part of the European Union.
In 2004 there was an election and there were
widespread reports of vote-rigging, but the
Russian-friendly Viktor Yanukovych was elected.
The opposition leader, Viktor Yushchenko,
lead massive street protests in Kiev that
came to be known as the Orange Revolution.
That opposition leader, Yushchenko, was disfigured
and almost died as a result of mysterious
poisoning.
Side note, but the number of "mysterious poisonings"
in Russia and Eastern Europe has absolutely
skyrocketed since Putin came to power in Russia,
which I'm sure is a coincidence.
Anyway, the Orange Revolution protests led
to a second election, and the poisoned opposition
leader, Yushchenko, won, and yay, everything
would be made of puppies and freedom and rainbows
and friendliness toward Europe forever, except
NO.
For one thing, a lot of people in Ukraine,
especially in the western part, want to be
more closely allied with Russia, and also
(despite being an economist) Yushchenko wasn't
very good at running the Ukrainian economy.
Also, Yushchenko couldn't push through austerity
measures needed to deal with Ukraine's rising
debt, and his friendliness towards Europe
infuriated Russia, which cut off gas supplies
briefly (but disastrously) to Ukraine in 2006.
So, by 2010, Ukraine was being led by the
Europe friendly, and somewhat corrupt, Yulia
Tymoshenko and then there were elections.
And the presidential election, declared free
and fair by international observers, was won
by the aforementioned, Russian-friendly, Viktor
Yanukovych.
In November 2013, Yanukovych announced that
Ukraine would abandon an agreement to strengthen
ties with the EU and would instead become
a closer ally of Russia.
And that is when the protests began in Kiev's
Independence Square.
Those protests grew and grew until February
20th when dozens of protesters were killed
by military and police and the next day Yanukovych
disappeared from Kiev.
The protesters had won.
They installed a new temporary government
to prepare for new elections... and then the
Putin regime marched into the Crimean Peninsula,
ostensibly to protect ethnic Russians there
and Russian military installations, but this
violation of Ukraine's territorial integrity
is known in diplomatic circles as, like, "a
big 'effing deal."
Crimea is already an autonomous province with
its own government, so what does it want?
Does it want independence?
That would be hard, all of their electricity
and water has to come through Ukraine.
Does it want to be part of Russia again?
That would be impossible, without Ukrainian
co-operation, which right now seems inconceivable,
so that's where we are right now.
I mean, unless something has happened in the
last 30 minutes.
So here's one narrative of these events: an
unpopular and ineffective, but democratically
elected politician was removed from power
by a mob of protesters, and the new, unelected
parliament briefly passed a law saying that
only Ukrainian can be the official language
of the country, even though many people in
the country speak Russian.
Furthermore, this new government wants to
become part of the EU which might bring NATO
missiles to Russia's border and that is unacceptable
to Russia.
I mean, I'm American.
We've had some very infective and unpopular
leaders, and what we've done is just waited
for them not to be president anymore.
But here's another narrative: a tyrannical
leader who ordered the murder of peaceful
protesters was chased from power and replaced
by a government that will transition Ukraine
toward free and fair elections and Russia
responded to that by invading Ukraine.
Hank, I'm not trying to make a false equivalence
here, but I think it's really important to
understand both of these narratives.
And I wanted to give a little more historical
context than we've been seeing on the news
because it helps us to understand that the
pull between Western Europe and Russia in
Ukraine is not new.
I mean, the word "Ukraine" itself means "borderland".
It has for centuries functioned as the border
between West and East.
What Ukraine needs is stability...
decades of stability, so it can grow to have
its own identity to have relationships with
both Europe and Russia without being controlled
by either.
Right now that dream seems really far away
but 60 years ago Japan was in ruins. 25 years
ago Germany was divided into two countries.
12 years ago Sierra Leone was mired in a horrific
and seemingly endless civil war but today
it's the second fastest growing economy in
the world.
The arc of history is long, Hank, let's hope
that it bends towards peace.
Hank, I'll see you on Friday.